good to see you look where's this money
coming from
so the bids will be paid for by the
Football Association so what it is it's
a joint bid between the UK and Ireland
to host the World Cup in 2030 but
obviously want there to be a legacy from
that so it's a 550 million pound
investment in grassroots football we'd
already in september announced a youth
investment fund and so their 150 million
pounds from that and for every 1 pound
of government money put in that
obviously unlocks private funding as
well that takes us through till 2024 and
then obviously there'll be further
budget announcements in due course and
our you know what we said about the
investment in capital and infrastructure
yeah I mean if it is still a lot of
money though in that investment in
grassroots football I mean aside from
the bid for 2030 we're a footballing
nation no two ways about it but there
are lots of other sports who would like
to get their hands on some money what
why plate the big boys in this way well
I think you're right football is
obviously a huge sport for our country
at 12 million people participate at a
grassroots level in in England alone we
know that for example it's becoming the
biggest participation sport for women
walking for all for people with
disabilities is also growing in
importance and actually what the money
would do is is provide two thousand more
3g pitches and also replace about 20,000
or upgrade about 20,000 grass pitches
now of course many of those pictures
particular 3G pictures can be used for
other sports as well and that's also
important we've seen that with previous
investments in certainly the larger
facilities where we say they've got to
be fought for multi use so not just for
football but football is obviously it's
important sport is important in terms of
bringing the nation together making sure
that we are healthier and happier and we
think this is a you know it's an
exciting that's but this is when the
Prime Minister talks about unleashing
Britain's potential this is exactly what
we are talking about the ability of
sport the soft path provides the UK
organises these events really really
well we saw that with Olympic Games we
are obviously seeing the Commonwealth
Games in 2022 we do obviously various
you know that heard of England and it's
the Tour de France so you know it's it's
a very important part of as
bringing people together and that came
up with the debate last night I think
it's important part of where we need to
go the next Parliament
I mean there's an irony here though
isn't there that won't be you know a lot
of people are gonna pick up on and the
idea that we want to encourage
grassroots football and grassroots
smaller sports the idea that we need
youngsters and teenagers to to be more
active all these sort of things I mean
it's really not that many years ago we
sold off a whole load of of playing
field schools we're getting rid of them
left right and center to make extra
money and we chasing our tail here well
okay I think they're always going to be
decisions that have been made in the
past and it may well be
I mean obviously there were there were
reasons to sell the pictures off in the
fields off at the time and we're talking
about new pitches so for example the 3G
pitches are new I mean I think that they
they've been around for a few years but
I know from my own local experience that
actually they provide sports and
training facilities all year round
they are multi-use and so I think what
we're talking about is investment in the
pitches for the future and of course you
know we've we've the government launched
a school sport action plan in the summer
we're also talking about more money to
go to making sure that there's more
sport in a teacher training for PE
teachers in secondary schools the sport
premium is now 320 million pounds we're
going to ask Ofsted to inspect school
sport but the other part of the youth
investment fund we also want to make
better use overall of school estates we
know that actually many young people and
their parents and families will feel
that they're safe when they're in a
school environment and actually we're
able to help schools to keep those
facilities open for longer helping them
financially to be able to it to do that
that's another important part of
developing all those extra skills and
characteristics we want young people to
have can we talk about V NHS just for a
moment and the document that was being
brandished around by Jeremy Corbyn you
know a week or so ago in which it was
claimed that the NHS was on the table in
discussions in post brexit talks I mean
the Prime Minister rubbished it at the
time now read it's the the social media
group was saying they've suspended I
think 61 accounts
to publishing this report they say there
is some link to some sort of Russian
interference should we be concerned yes
I think we obviously should be concerned
and it's obviously those who seem to
know more who follow this when
information like this is published are
asserting as you say that this has the
hallmarks of Russian interference and
it's something that we have to be alive
to and have to watch in terms of our
democratic processes as you say the
content already the Prime Minister have
made very clear that actually that was
not reflect government policy the NHS
absolutely is not for sale it's not on
the table we heard that confirmed again
this this week and I think you know it's
not it doesn't it doesn't become our
political debate for documents to be
flourished around that don't then
support the assertions that are being
made and if this is the result of
over-seasoned interference trying to
influence elections then obviously that
is a real concern and it's good to good
to call these things out as quickly as
possible but if there is concern over
the potential at least of Russian
interference or attempted Russian
interference in our electoral process
doesn't this highlight that the
Intelligence and Security Committee
report which has been produced has been
greenlit but still hasn't been released
by the government doesn't highlight
they've actually we should be able to
see that well the issue with the report
is that the way that reports only it is
sent to to government and that it's
published it to Parliament and because
of the the speed at which obviously
Parliament was a dissolve once the
election was was called in order to make
sure that the polling day was the 12th
of December which I think was the last
feasible date before Christmas there
hasn't been a parliament to publish that
report - but all I can say is that the
government obviously is taking steps we
are very aware of the potential for
overseas interference and watching very
carefully through lots of different
channels as to what potentially might be
going on and as I say it's important
that these things absolutely are called
out and called out both politically but
also called out by those who monitor and
spot overseas interference and
you mentioned the debate last night and
obviously it's it's a sort of hot topic
and sort of nuts in the way because it
was a bit of a no score or between the
two leaders I think that's probably
pretty fair to say but Trust was an
issue that came up particularly with
Boris Johnson and now we have a diplomat
who's come forward Alexandra Hall Hall
who says who says keep their mouths shut
she's there quitting her position saying
I'm at a stage in life where I prefer to
do something more rewarding with my time
than peddle half-truths on behalf of a
government I do not trust now that is a
hugely damning statement from someone
who is is meant to work for whichever
administration is in power well firstly
I think it's obviously a matter of
regret when a senior official someone in
the Diplomatic Service who works the
Foreign Office decides that they don't
want to carry on and she will have
obviously her reasons some which I think
are set out obviously she doesn't go
into the detail about exactly what she
has felt so concerned and unhappy about
but I think what I would say is and it's
where you started this question is on
the issue of trust and the biggest
breach of trust has been that people
voted in this country of our majority to
leave the European Union in 2016 and
three and a half years later Parliament
has not delivered on that in fact has
been paralysed which is the reason that
we're having this election brexit of
course has been difficult and
challenging not just for for diplomats
but for many people but it has paralyzed
Parliament to the extent that we've not
been able to resolve brexit and not be
able to get on talked about other things
and that's why I think there the debate
last night the what was clear was the
leadership shown by Boris Johnson got a
deal people said he couldn't get it's
going to be approved to get the majority
Conservative government by the end of
January the UK will leave the EU
compared to Jeremy Corbyn who's not able
to say what his position would be on the
second referendum that he says he wants
and he says he's gonna negotiate her
leave deal but it's not clear actually
how he would be taken seriously by the
EU who he's not then going to advocate
for that deal and then we spend 2020
arguing about to further referendums one
on the E
and one on Scotland if we had a Labour
SNP coalition that is not moving forward
which is what we wanted to do as a
Conservative government yeah I mean to
be fair to mr. Walsh she does give some
further details
she says she's dismayed by the way in
which our political leaders have tried
to deliver brexit with the reluctance to
address honestly
the challenges and trade-offs that
brexit involves the use of misleading or
disingenuous arguments about the
implications of the various options
before us now is she overstepping her
mark by using a personal perspective on
this or is she actually raising a valid
point to say actually whichever side you
listen to here we're not getting a clear
answer I think she's obviously outlining
her concerns and you know it is unusual
clearly for somebody in her position to
be quite so open and honest about what
the difficulties that she's had and
obviously that sir that's a matter for
those in the embassy in Washington but
also in that the Foreign Office but I
think what she is getting at is that a
brexit is it is complex and you know
there have been various many debates but
she talked there about I think you said
about the political leaders not having
clearly I mean I think there's a
frustration on all sides in the country
on the doorsteps that Parliament was
given a task which was to honor the
result of the referendum and has not
been able to do that and the other day
it was a simple thing the country voted
by a majority of those voting to leave
the European Union and that should have
happened by the 29th of March and didn't
and it's taken the current Prime
Minister Boris Johnson to go back to
Brussels to negotiate a new deal to then
say we're going to have this election I
want a majority because that's the way
we're going to liver it and move forward
as a country and I think that that is
the mark of the leadership that I think
that she is looking for you talk about
the current prime minister what about
the past Prime Minister Sir John Major I
mean it is quite something when a former
conservative Prime Minister cannot back
at the current conservative prime
minister in the run-up to the to the
election I mean I wonder if you do you
have any sympathy for John Major's
position bearing in mind but actually
his view on brexit is surely much more
aligned with your
there is too Boris Johnson well no all
that latter point that's not correct I
think I think so John is advocating now
for a second referendum which is
something that I wholly oppose that's
why I think it's so important we have a
clear result next week in the general
election so we're able to move forward
get the bill through the House of
Commons and move on in 2020 it's why I
absolutely think that the suggestion by
the day party of a second referendum is
such a mistake so John obviously um you
know was a was a an exit prime minister
very distinguished of course he'll have
his opinions I think what he said was
that if he lived in the constituents
because it should seize all the
independence that he would vote for them
so he wasn't saying don't vote
conservative but but he's absolutely
entitled to his opinions and again Boris
Johnson addressed that head-on last
night he said that he and Sir John Major
like the rest of us as conservatives
would agree on many many things but on
the issue of Europe and brexit there is
a difference of opinion and it's a
contrast because Jeremy Corbyn couldn't
even utter I don't think Tony Blair's
name during that that debate and that
shows that yes as conservatives will
have different views on brexit but we
agree on many many other things Nicky
Morgan good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed